. Continuing with unsurprising corona virus
news.
Schools of all kinds of started to open elementary,
middle high school colleges and universities
and corona virus clusters are exploding now.
I wish I could say, you know, it really seemed
like this wasn't going to happen.
We're shocked by this.
This was it was just unpredictable.
We knew that this was going to happen.
A few stories from around the country at Purdue
University.
Cases, student cases on campus are already
at 41 within just a few days of students moving
in.
Remember that it often takes five days to
show symptoms.
So certainly it's more than 41 cases that
will ultimately be discovered at Purdue Universities
campus.
In Florida, nearly 9000 kids have tested positive
in the two weeks since schools reopened.
That brings the total number of cases in Florida
among those under 18 to close to 50000 cases.
If you look across the country, you have about
750 colleges and universities now with cases.
University of North Carolina is a bad one.
They've had to send most undergraduate students
home already.
It's not even September.
North Carolina had so many cases in the dorms
that most undergrads have already been sent
home.
Notre Dame is delaying classes because dozens
of students have tested positive there.
Iowa State, dozens of cases in the dorms.
One of the worst outbreaks is at the University
of Alabama at Birmingham, where there are
nearly a thousand cases.
University of Central Florida, 750 cases.
I'm not going to give you the whole list,
but it's everywhere.
And it was completely predictable.
Now, I want to remind everybody in the audience,
because every time I talk about this, I get
the same confused emails.
I am not pretending, especially when it comes
to school age, kids, elementary, middle school,
high school, that this is a simple issue.
This is not a simple issue.
You have parents who can't work if their kids
aren't in school.
You have parents that have jobs that you can't
work from home, but they don't pay enough
to pay for childcare, meaning it wouldn't
make sense if their kids are at home to go
to work and pay for childcare.
They just can't work.
They've got to stay home.
That's a systemic problem with the country.
We've not done enough in terms of stimulus
compared to other countries.
It is a complicated situation, but it is a
systemic problem.
You, of course, have parents who just insist
this is no big deal and want to send their
kids to school.
You have parents who believe, you know, corona
virus conspiracy theories.
You have all that stuff.
But the real problem is not so much parents
choosing to send their kids to school because
they're not worried about the virus.
This is really a systemic problem that has
put a lot of parents into untenable situations.
Now, that's different than colleges and universities.
We're talking about if things go correctly,
you just need to do remote learning in the
fall.
Clearly, this fall semester should be done
remote.
It should be done online.
It should have been done from day one.
Some schools did it.
Others have refused to do it.
We're not talking about forever.
And I get that if you're an incoming freshman,
this is not a fun way to start college.
This is probably not even the best way to
start college.
From the perspective of learning, I get it.
But let's not miss the forest for the trees
having to shut down a semester in progress
and send people home sometimes days after
the semester started.
It's way more disruptive than just saying,
hey, guys, you know, it sucks, but we're going
to do remote for the fall.
And then hopefully in the spring we can start
to go back to normal, spending the time developing
a good remote learning system for the fall
rather than bringing students in endless testing
cases pop up sending students home.
It would have made far more sense.
Elementary, middle, high school.
I'm not pretending it isn't complicated.
The problems are more systemic than they are
individual.
Our federal government has failed quite simply.